ذات مرة كانت هناك سيارة كانت
السيارة الصغيرة التي كان بإمكان الأمريكيين فييستا أن يعرفوك
بالكاد ، لكن
البريطانيين لم يتمكنوا من الحصول على ما يكفي ،
ربما بدأت علاقة حبهم بعد
ظهورك بجانب جيمس بوند
روجر مور أو ربما كانت
قدرتك على الوقوف  اختبار الوقت
هذا هو Ford Fiesta الجديد الذي
يحتوي على القليل من العتاد
لكل شخص على مر العقود ، حيث
تمكنت غالبًا من البقاء على رأس
قوائم المبيعات في المملكة المتحدة ، وهي علامة تجارية أمريكية أنتجت لأول مرة
في إسبانيا في السبعينيات  وبعد ذلك
صنعت في ألمانيا ، أتيت عندما كان
العالم في أمس الحاجة إليك
في خضم أزمة النفط ،
احتاج السائقون إلى شيء أكثر اقتصادا ، ويمكنك
بسهولة ملء هذا الدور ،
لم يكن لدى Ford Fiesta أبدًا هندسة أكثر تقدمًا
في سيارة صغيرة تقدم لاحقًا نفس
الأجراس  وصفارات السيارات الأكثر فخامة
، وعندما تحاول سيارات الدفع الرباعي والندوب
تجاوزك ، فإنك تحمل
صديقًا مخلصًا تأقلم مع The
Changing Times وأصبح
رياضيًا مؤخرًا  r نسخة ملونة أكثر من
نفسك
الآن ولا حتى 50 عامًا ،
ويتم وضعك في المراعي لإفساح المجال
لجيل جديد من الطرز الكهربائية والهجينة
بينما من المحتمل أن تظل
مرغوبًا ومحبوبًا من قبل
معجبيك للأسف ، لقد حان المهرجان  نهاية
لذلك نقول الآن شكرا لك أيتها الفتاة الصغيرة
على كل ما فعلته